we're going to be getting a Cinematic
Universe based on the miniature game
Warhammer all thanks to Henry Cavill and
this is the full story with a few
interesting little twists and turns
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel would have to be my
Warhammer stuff
we're doing the Games Workshop aren't we
yeah yeah yeah it's um that took me a
while to kind of um confess to openly
and publicly
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
so when Henry Cavill announced that he
was leaving The Witcher we were all a
little confused and then the news hit
that actually he was going to be
returning his Superman so we all assumed
that's it he's returning to the Superman
so can't do both he can't be in The
Witcher and have a full-time job at the
DC can he now I always thought that was
still a little bit strange because
obviously you can do movies in a TV
series at the same time people have done
it before but maybe there was lots of
projects that Henry Cavill was signing
on to with the DC so okay maybe that
explained it but then we hear that
actually the DC are not going to be
moving forward to Henry Cavill as a
Superman it actually seems that they see
us scrapping everything to do the
Cincinnati Universe even Black Adam
so why did Henry Cavill step down from
The Witcher has he gone and shot himself
in the foot and made himself unemployed
foreign
well no it turns out that him stepping
down from the witch actually had nothing
to do with wanting to do Superman but
everything to do with him wanting to do
the Warhammer and actually everything to
do with the sort of person Henry Cavill
is uh it's more Hammer gray
so what you see you you paint by hand
yes yeah does everyone do that or can
you buy them or no you have to paint
them he is a gamer he is a geek he has
talked repeatedly about how he likes
painting the Warhammer Miniatures and he
does that to relax he builds PCS on
YouTube videos and so on and so on now
there was a lot of rumors that actually
that geekiness was a big problem for him
on The Witcher because not all the
executive producers Etc shared it and
they kept wanting to change the
character and make it more interesting
for a cinema Universe instead of
sticking to the actual story and what
was The Witcher
this became more and more frustrating
Foundry Cavill and led finally to the
decision for him to come away from The
Witcher now he has been working
apparently on this Warhammer project for
a long time
um I mean the easy answer is Warhammer
40 000 that is my my jab
um I have been into it since I was 10.
what's your army at the moment uh
custodies ah yeah I'm going I'm going
necrons next okay all right cool now
you'll know if you're a regular side
tracker Amazon are actually desperately
looking for somebody to make the new
Stargate franchise they may have got a
production company and they need other
partners to be able to produce that
series
including they need to find hopefully a
lead actor somebody they could get
behind somebody that can actually be the
front man for the show like Richard Dean
Anderson was first time around for
Stargate sg1
this project with Warhammer is literally
the exact opposite Henry Cavill the big
star a man who people know is in
desperately wanting to do this for ages
I suppose I could play a different
character from the Warhammer fantasy
Universe versus the 40K universe but
again
now just dreaming so I'd have to speak
to the guys at Games Workshop and then
see what happens he's partnered up with
Natalie vascuso and vertigo who will
then produce the TV show with him or
will it just be a TV show I'm coming
back down in a second
with them they actually started
developing a project and then that's how
they got in touch with Amazon Amazon
then went through the process of
beginning contracts with a workshop
games Who currently own the copyright of
the Warhammer franchise now those
contracts are not actually agreed yet
and that is important because my source
is Amazon are telling me that actually
Henry Cavill begged Amazon to announce
this project early they didn't want to
announce it just yet the contracts as I
say are not technically finalized they
have an agreement in principle only also
normally Amazon would like a much more
development to be done on the TV show
before it announced the idea being you
developed the TV show you get some
scripts you get a really good idea of
what you want to do before you announce
it because it is only at the end of the
development period that you actually
make the final decision on whether you
want to make the show or not so you
could announce a big project
go through all the development process
and then decided to load a rubbish and
not do it now that happens quite a lot
to be honest lots of TV shows are
announced that never happen but it's
embarrassing for the company Amazon
don't like to do it so why did they do
it in this case well Henry Cavill
stepped down as a Witcher and that was
seen as quite a negative thing by a lot
of fans they didn't quite understand it
he then found out he wasn't getting the
Superman gig and that again created
quite a lot of negativity around him
none of that negativity aimed at Henry
to be fair but still that negativity so
he went to Amazon and said let's
announce Warhammer there's a lot of
people going crazy over me not being
Superman me not being The Witcher let's
give them something and Amazon agreed so
they announced the intention to develop
with Henry Cavill a Warhammer TV series
now again according to my sources at
Amazon they actually intend to do far
more than just a TV series now I've been
hearing rumors about them trying to get
the Warhammer
um contract for a while
um Amazon really do like projects that
they can go across different genres so
they like the fact that it's a board
game they could dependence you become a
video game that can potentially become a
TV series and also more importantly
potentially become a series of movies
now again just like Stargate Amazon are
looking for big franchises something
they can do lots of different things
with so at the moment the plan is to
develop the project and see where it
goes but Amazon are pushing and are
talking to Henry Cavill and vertigo
about the potential to make a straight
to cinema movie potentially to kick
start the franchise again just like they
would like to do with Stargate now this
is going to very much depend on what the
creators when they they are finally
hired want to do because Henry Cavill is
going to be an executive producer but
they haven't actually got writers
directors
etc etc yet on board
once those people are found and a
creative future is decided Amazon would
love that future to go this cinematic
route and then multiple TV series on the
Amazon Prime Network
so let's see what happens but what I can
tell you right now is that Henry Cavill
is desperate to do this he is a massive
geek for the story and he knows all too
well that this franchise has massive
scope the stories based in and around
Warhammer go across thousands of years
tens of thousands of years across
multiple planets and so on and so on
there is a huge amount of information
and a huge amount of stories there very
much like sort of a marvel-esque type of
project Warhammer could go in a lot so
in lots of different directions with
Henry Cavill right in the middle of it I
cannot wait to see what they're going to
do with this absolute Behemoth of
potential sci-fi brilliance
but guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think do you think this is a
project you're pretty excited about or
is it something like mayor whatever I'd
love to know exactly what you think and
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content and you want to
support the channel even further
consider hitting the join button as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
[Music]